This is a brutal weapon.
This is
the Danish bearded ax.
It's capable of dealing
brutal blows.
Historical sources indicate
it was used by the elite troops
among the Saxons
and the Normans.
The similarities and the
differences between this
and a longsword
in the Armored Combat League --
a longsword is gonna be
light up at the tip,
heavy -- heavier in the hilt.
-Right.
This is heavier in the tip,
lighter in the hilt.
Um, we don't really use
half-swording techniques
because they're not effective
for what we do,
because we're not --
we're not doing
any piercing, any thrusting.
-Right.
Or the trapping
and breaking of arms.
Right. For the most part,
a longsword,
you got the weight in your hand
and it's for singles.
Longsword is not
very effective in melee,
because
it doesn't hit hard.
It can hit fast,
it can hit accurately,
but it's not
gonna hit hard.
Therefore, it can be
ignored in melee.
This weapon cannot be
Cannot be ignored.
[ Chuckles ]
Um, if you miss a block
with this,
you're gonna be hurt
or you're gonna be stunned.
You should also put it like
this -- If you try to ignore it,
it can get your attention
pretty damn fast.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Exactly.
♪♪
But you'll see fighters using
this not only offensively,
but also putting it over the top
of their opponent's head...
-Mm-hmm. Right.
-...and then controlling them,
and using it
to throw opponents.
Going up and just hitting
to the front
or the back of the head.
The small "beard,"
or lower portion,
it's possible that you can
ward a shot with the haft
and then use that
to pull his weapon down,
and then return another hit
before he can recover.
Right.
And in tight quarters, you'll
see like we've seen before --
at-range, out here;
mid-range, choked up tight.
The thumbs are facing inboard,
and now you're using this to --
to pummel and throw shots
with your body into the face,
almost like
a punching action.
Wow, yeah.
That's interesting.
Ooh,
that's gonna be good.
So it is -- it's a pretty
versatile weapon.
It is.
Really versatile.
Yeah. You'd think it's simply
just chop, chop, chop.
But it has its own
particular techniques.
♪♪